what's up guys are welcome to what is
probably going to be the last episode of
this entire let's play park thing rose
gardens thing that's going on here
because you know like I said I'm
probably going to run everything up
right now in this episode I'm going to
keep it fairly small and simple and
actually do some behind the screens work
here because you know it is kind of
boring stuff that I'm going to want to
do here and made a small little bucket
list for that which got a couple of
points in it that I kind of want to
address when it comes to this park which
is like stuff like the path work
definitely needs to be worked on and
there's a lot of benches and little bins
and stuff that's missing and some areas
could definitely use some planters here
and there other stuff like this area is
a bit bare and the biggest issue that
I'm having with this park is the park
layout it's not as it's not really that
great and not too happy with it but it's
something that you know I can't really
change anyway so I'm just going to have
to kind of work around that and see if I
can make this look better without having
to change all that so it's mainly the
details that I'm going to be focusing on
in these last episodes or at least in
this last episode because that's lazily
planning at the moment and first of all
I kind of want to yeah I'll take all
those path works could definitely use
some work here so yeah first of all I
had the idea to come up with this the
gallery thing over here I don't know if
that's actually going to work but you
know there's looping areas looking a bit
boring right now it needs something need
some some cool stuff over here so I'm
going to try to like build some kind of
roof on top of pillars over here and see
if that's going to work out yeah turns
out that the wainscot from Main Street
set actually work pretty damn well with
those posts from shyguys alpine village
five so I kind of want to try doing this
and just put a roof on this and see how
that looks okay I still want to spice up
the area a bit more but I think this
looks pretty cool I'd like the
automating roof collars and your evening
at these wooden beams in the middle
which actually have a pretty awesome
effect on this entire thing so I'm
looking at it from a distance it's still
a bit boring because there's nothing
next to it but you know I think I'll
work on that and at least I'm going to
add some well lampposts and stuff like
that on the sides to definitely make
this look a bit more also
so that's definitely going to work out
never mind that though I changed the
color of this roof do something that
seems to be more appropriate something
that's less out there and just you know
cyntha sting is just a side kind of
thing and just to fill that just to fill
up the space which was kind of bare I
feel like just more like less
contrasting colors would actually be
better than the red I had before but for
some reason these walls over here broken
so I kind of need to repair that real
quick so the next thing on my list is to
go to my good old pal Weber and get one
of his trunks and branches and stuff
like that and this might seem like a
stupid idea but it's something that
people have been done for quite a while
now I think you just go to that one set
if I can find it that is with all my
years of experience I still always lose
sets there it is the foliage is set and
this title by the way does not lie it is
exactly what it says to be and you get
these awesome tree branches and logs and
trunks and stuff like that I mean stumps
so that's what they're called and you
just ban them or at least don't spend
them too much but you know this has been
a thing for quite a while now and people
have always liked to spam these things
and I've always liked to just do what
the rest of the community does and you
all know that that's not exactly what is
happening right here it's just something
that you can throw in the ground and
things will look less boring and these
these branches and stuff like that it
does make sense I have them in forests
you know you always have these falling
branches and broken trunks and look like
that so it's a pretty cool Sun get a
watch out when you're terraforming
though because you know that thing is
kind of tricky you can't have to get
them to be right to not float around
which can be an issue at times but it's
really not all that bad usually you can
find something although it seems that
today is not that day okay I kind of
have to find that certain position where
it actually kind of does work out I
guess that is that's good enough for
that place right there and you'll find
that this side is actually quite full of
items that you can use for whatever like
care there's a little ground cover thing
I've never been too much of a fan of
these things but if you can kind of like
hide them and incorporate them into some
scenery items then you can always just
you know have these things around it's
always a cool thing to
have these little details on the ground
and not just have antique grasslands to
look at though this honestly only really
works when you're in a forest II setting
like this because I wouldn't want to
place all kinds of stuff like this if
you're just you know in the middle of a
theme park and you actually do have a
neat little patch of cross and I'm
really a big fan of these greenery
Crossy things norm
normos of these shrubs are not really
all that awesome either but no there's
some pretty good items in this sir
you know there are times when I really
hate the advanced camera because you
know it can be so annoying but at times
you just really need it you know I feel
like this is one of those times well
without that thing and we've ever had to
go through so much trouble to actually
reach those places you know I might just
call it a day for this building like
this because I think it's pretty much
good pretty much good to go
except for a report of course the path
work one of the few things on my to-do
list right now no [ __ ] passed me it says
add pot details everywhere okay then
let's see a set called Matt's lighting
set came up pretty recently but so far
I've seen mostly Matty using it and it's
a pretty damn awesome set and you know
this is I think I'm actually like it
more than four teens lighting kit which
has been at the to go light set so far
but this set has some really awesome
lamps in it so you should definitely
pick this up if you don't have it yet
and no to self though if you're about to
play something which is very close to
something else with a really big hitbox
especially a flat ride don't do it this
is this is always a problem can I like
can i you know this is if I'm going to
have to remove this flap right it is not
going to be the first time I'm going to
have to do that simply because this I
mean this is a tie ring process I don't
even know if at this point I can
actually remove that thing well nope
here we go I've probably made this
combination one too many times but
seriously I can't not make it this is
just this is just a perfect combination
of like a little flower bush and just
the perfectly fitting it's all pop
beneath that it is
just great and it works in any situation
so also little thing now the next thing
that I'm going to have to do is it was
my list let me get up spice up the
intamin pond uh that makes perfect sense
okay
there's a couple things when you have a
pond and you don't really know what to
do with it you can always just found
water lilies even if it's not the most
realistic thing to do it's just
something that makes it look more
interesting and there's a number of sets
you can go with I think but I'm just
gonna go with and sevens water lilies
for one because they have a random
placement which is always great when
you're trying to place foliage and you
don't want everything to look very
unnatural but it also has some really
amazing you know the things underneath
the leaves all right I don't even know
what you call them but the things that
connect them to the ground and stuff
like that and there's flowers so it's a
good set alright I really think there's
nothing else to it it's displacing water
lilies though in this case I would say
that this texture this little darker
texture does actually go better with
this overall atmosphere I'm going for it
then these like oh my god stop do not
come on the heart of be right back
okay hold up as I'm trying to as I'm
trying to gain my composure again here I
don't I don't think I've saved no ok
I've replaced these little buggers and
tried to come back to my little pond
here and you know it's pretty much been
taken over by ducks and these are these
are the actual in-game ducks and ah
there you go [ __ ] off please I need to I
need to place my water lilies here but I
just noticed about this set which is
actually a really nice detail is that
the names have actually been taken from
some of my favorite roller coastering
three like people out there like
fisherman is somebody who makes awesome
dark rides
I think lien is is a reference to
Leonidas who makes just the best
buildings out there and here's bill otto
and these are all just awesome roller
coastering three stuff creators so that
is really awesome by the way don't pay
too much attention on my water lillies
here I am no expert on water lilies I
don't even know how these things
actually work in real life so I probably
[ __ ] up
like the majority of them in place way
too many in one pond and like not on the
right way but yeah it's just one small
pond hopefully is it going to be okay
with a little fountain in it because
what's a pond with in a fountain
I mean what's a pond without a fountain
oh that is pretty cool
like in an outer opposites but within
has nothing to do with there has nothing
to do with without hmm and that's when
trusty old Ralphie's fountain started
crushing again done with this if there's
any reason why I should probably stop
doing this it might be because of this
obviously yeah this is the point where I
realized that Ralphie's fountain set
does not want to work today and just
keeps crashing on me
so I think you know with just getting
these windows done and doing something
in the back side of this building the
park is nearly finished and this is
going to be about it and one thing that
I do want to talk about while I try to
do these winners over here and try to do
some terrible effort to actually
multitask is the fact that I'm going to
call it a day here and actually just
finish the park and not look back on it
and you could argue that the park is not
finished there are probably a couple of
details that I would actually you know
improve upon if I would actually do that
if I would actually take the time to you
know improve the park until I actually
feel good about it but then again I
don't know when a park is actually
finished and if you leave me to just
keep adding details and keep changing
things until I'm happy about it you know
I might as well just lock myself up in
my room forever with this park and never
be done with this so yeah I think there
is nothing I can really add to this Park
to make it substantially better so this
is really about the time when I finish
this thing and get this over with and
make the video and you know do something
else in the game because truth be told
and I've probably said this before but
it's almost like I've worked on this
part for too long and wouldn't
necessarily call that a problem the only
issue is that this park has the same
general overarching theme throughout the
same park so it has some areas some
slightly differently themed areas but
you know you still get the drill it's
still kind of similar throughout this
in Pike and you know I'm almost it I'm
almost getting tired of it
and there's loads of ideas I want to try
for a new Pike and maybe even making
time lapses of other small projects but
first I need to finish this and also I
have exams coming up pretty soon
so yeah I'm sorry if I'm not uploading
too many videos at the moment but this
is going to be it for a while also and
this goes without saying I think we've
once again proven that Ralphie's
Arabians set to work with anything and
anything ever and so it is that we say
goodbye to rose gardens I think this is
pretty much it I don't think I'll be
doing any more work in any let's play
episode on this particular Park I might
add a couple of details before you know
I start recording but it's nothing
really worth mentioning or showing and
that recording process is probably going
to happen in a few weeks because I've
got exams coming up but maybe just
possibly when I do have the time to do
some small things I will work and you
know start on the new park and I will
you know keep going with the let's play
in that new Park before I actually
upload the video of this because this is
going to take quite a while I still want
to work on my own music for it and kind
of went to try and some new techniques
on actually editing this and you know
add it like a quote-unquote professional
person once instead of just slapping all
the things in Sony Vegas and then
dropping my fist on the keyboard until
something okay comes out so there's some
pretty good Disney merchandise there now
for all you fellows that actually do
want to like see more of the park before
that happens
we've got the oh yeah we've got the
flying coaster right here it's looking
cool and all and you know it also does
this little curve around this thing
which I'm not sure if I really wanted to
do this in the end you know it looks
cool but it's somewhere over fast like
false little part of the ride we're
supposed to be a family ride but it's
actually quite intense for this type a
ride I do really like the station though
there is the big invert which is
definitely way too long but then again
that's what I like about it
which also got a really weird station
I'm still not sure about this but
honestly this just started out as a
terrible station and I just started
adding random [ __ ] until it looks okay
and that's how I ended up with this and
what else is now the internment coaster
of course you know I wasn't sure about
the towers but I decided to keep them
this way because simplistic as they may
be and weird as their design maybe this
is just hang on this is how the riders
in the end I don't think any changing is
going to significantly alter these
things to the point where I like them
more because chances are if I start
doing that it'll just look like
something completely different and not
the spooky weird uncanny kind of thing
that it was supposed to be also this is
probably my favorite restaurant I've
built at least in this park you know
it's pretty simple and using somewhat
common sense but no I don't know it's
pretty cute and the last area of course
which is like one big facade first right
here too bad you don't actually see too
much of those four saunas and everything
but here's the carousel building that
too so here's the pike this is it I'll
see you all next time in which I don't
know yeah okay I need to stop recording
before I get too emotional [ __ ] this in
all seriousness though this park has
taken almost a year to build or was it
more it might actually have been more
anyway it's taking a very long time and
if I look at it right now
I'm just like wait why did I take all
that time just for this Pike it doesn't
even seem that big and yes those facades
in the front right there are unfinished
at the back it's not like you actually
see those things but it's been pretty
fun to built this bike and now that I
can I just kind of want to thank
everyone for all their awesomeness so
all the people on YouTube who have
actually been following this park and
then let's play and then leaving
comments and likes and all that I love
you and all the people on the forums who
have actually responded to the threads
and helped me just the general ways not
even related to this park I love you too
and I'll see you all soon in a new
park and I've no idea what it's going to
be yet and I guess I'll just let my
brain decide but you'll see in due time